[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
émission spéciale ryder cup au programme
aujourd'hui nous vous emmènerons du côté
est du centre médias lourds en
compteront également des bénévoles et
nous irons du côté de la cérémonie
d'ouverture
[Musique]
après avoir a dîné hier soir au château
de versailles en costume s'il vous plaît
les joueurs américains et les joueurs
européens se sont rendus aujourd'hui sur
les greens pour s'entraîner à nouveau à
j moins un avant le début de la
compétition et ça a fait beaucoup de
bruit
il y avait beaucoup de supporters
[Applaudissements]
et comme vous pouvez le voir juste
derrière moi les supporters sont de plus
en plus nombreux à mes côtés bertrand de
nantes qui n'a pas hésité à faire le
voyage pour participer à l'événement et
qui a reçu je crois une serviette d'un
célèbre golfeur tout à fait dustin
johnson qui nous a gentiment donné ce
service de france étaient vraiment
formidable de sa part très gentil qu'est
ce que vous en pensez de cette ambiance
de tous ces golfeurs internationaux qui
sont près de vous c'est fabuleux ce
qu'on ne voit jamais joué en europe donc
c'est vraiment très sympa et de les voir
jouer c'est on voit le top niveau et
voir tiger woods aussi c'est quelque
chose d'incroyable parce qu'il incarne
vraiment le golf et c'est une légende
justement bertrand vous allez le voir
dans quelques instants ce tailleur bout
ce je vous laisse tranquille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et ses supporters seront encore plus
nombreux demain pour le départ du trou
numéro 1 à 8 heures cette tribune qui
est juste derrière moi sans rempli de
6800 personnes et tout autour il devrait
y avoir entre 20 et 30 mille à personne
mcilroy et tiger woods se souviennent de
leur premier trou numéro 1 1re ryder cup
je ne savais pas pourquoi tous les
genres en parler autant je pensais que
c'était simplement un événement par
équipe qui n'avait aucune importance au
sens large je me préoccupais plus de mes
titres individuels etc
et après quand je me suis avancé vers le
premier tiré le premier vendredi matin
c'était totalement différent de ce que
j'attendais j'étais nerveux
je suis sûr que vous étiez là au pays de
galles à l'époque et pour une raison que
je ne saurait m'expliquer une raison
acoustique
il y avait tellement de proximité que ça
résonnait est vraiment il y avait un
niveau sonore très élevé et au putting
green juste à côté du premier du premier
tee on pouvait même sentir ce bruit ils
ont forcément c'était une expérience
particulière j'ai adoré ça et je pense
que cette semaine sera à la hauteur ce
jeudi à 27 septembre c'est aussi
l'occasion de voir les anciens
capitaines de la ryder cup et ils sont
juste derrière moi interview audio pétri
aucune idée c'est pas bon je crois que
on joue pas beaucoup à voir surtout
avant tout l'image pour le magret les
mois on a joué et corey pavin a joué
quelques tours on a cette année mais
mais je crois que les restes
on joue pas beaucoup il sait pas c'est
passé qui est les favoris les favoris
oui bien sûr oui c'est vrai mais bon à
la fin il faut il faut battre il faut
jouer au golf et on verra
nous sommes à présent dans le temple de
la communication de cette ryder cup 2018
le centre média
[Musique]
oh
je pense que m 1000 personnes dans le
même endroit et de leur donner ce dont
ils ont besoin pour couvrir la ryder cup
c'est une chose incroyable
je pense que les installations ici sont
les meilleurs que nous avons eues sur
une ryder cup en europe
on essaye de grandir à chaque édition
est d'améliorer les installations pour
que les journalistes puissent raconter
l'histoire de la ryder cup
les chiffres donnent le tournis on
retrouve ici 920 journalistes accrédités
venus de 27 pays
au total 295 médias du monde entier sont
présents chaque jour sur ce média center
pendant la compétition
je suis ici j'arrive entre 6h30 et 8h30
c'est je pars à peu près après le repas
du soir
donc nous sommes ici plus ou moins toute
la journée j'écris pour le times je suis
correspondant golf pour le times depuis
longtemps c'est ma 21e ryder cup la
ryder cup ne serait rien sans eux les
volontaires ils sont 1 1500 sur cette
ryder cup 2018 et ils viennent du monde
entier
ils ne sont pas rémunérés mais ils sont
rémunérés à la passion nous avons
rencontré deux yvelinois il ya une
sélection qui est faite par le comité
d'organisation français américain en
fonction de dieu des rôles qui sont
attribués il ya 1500 bénévoles à peu
près et puis j'ai été choisi donc pour
pour gérer le trou numéro 2 sur les
chiffres de l'après midi et puis c'est
aussi pour voir un petit peu les les
champions internationaux de prêt et
pouvoir vivre au coeur d'un événement
qui est le troisième
troisième événement médiatique au monde
donc une chance unique a pas laissé
passer tout comme pierre chevalier
jacques morny président du club de golf
de montigny le bretonneux a été
sélectionné pour participer à la ryder
cup 2018 comme bénévole il est sur le
practice d'entraînement mon rôle ici
c'est de ses dettes à leur service entre
guillemets essentiellement de les
convoyant à leur fournir des balles donc
on a on
huit types de bal différent donc c'est
eux qui nous dise quelle balle ils
tapent la balle et souhaite taper et
puis on leur donne le sceau de balle on
fait attention qu'il ne manque pas de
balle déclare soho commence la devine on
leur demande s'ils en veulent d'autres
et puis s'ils veulent d'autres bals et
bien on le ramène à saint-saud
complémentaires et ensuite on nettoie la
place pour que le suivant ait une place
propre et qu'ils soient bien à l'aise
portable ses valses en panne et
s'échauffer
[Musique]
l'image du jour c'est évidemment cette
cérémonie d'ouverture on connaîtra enfin
le nom à des joueurs qui composeront les
équipes européennes et américaines sur
la journée de vendredi et il ya
également des chanteurs et bien sûr le
public est venu très nombreux
on va les écouter oui
[Applaudissements]
il
c'est la fin de cette émission spéciale
à ryder cup rendez vous demain pour de
nouvelles aventures golfique
[Musique]